je crois comme tout est fait pour qu'une
série ce soit confort quoi se dire qu'on
est on sait la domestication du cinéma
on est chez soi on a envie d'être un peu
bien quand on se regarde une série parce
que on n'est pas assez disons en santé
pour regarder un film donc on est dans
une moindre attention donc ça c'est bien
pour la série on sait les soirs on les
regarde et puis il faut que ce soit un
peu confort donc il faut aussi que
l'univers qui nous est présentée soit un
peu confortable un peu accueillant un
peu inclusif pourrais-je dire en
retournant négativement un mot que
auquel par ailleurs je m'associe est bas
les classes populaires bon comment dire
tout de suite c'est plus moche quoi
cdc des intérieurs plus moche c'est -
cosy sait moins c'est moins qu'aucun
comme on aurait dit dans les années 90
je pense que il ya quand même un effet
comme ça de de confort et j'en viens
quand même aussi à la limite à mon avis
idéologique de bondo netflix de ce
qu'elle produit comme série mais aussi
d'autres plateformes la limite
idéologique c'est qu'effectivement on va
pas dans les classes sociales et surtout
on va pas là où ça commence à faire mal
parce qu'il faut pas que ça fasse trop
mal quand même on est là pour inclure on
n'est pas là pour diviser or la grande
politique divise quoi je dirais donc
effectivement je pense que globalement
si on devrais je vais être grossier je
m'en excuse auprès de mes
interlocutrices tout de suite je vais
être généralisant excessivement je pense
que s'il y avait commandé une analogie
idéologique de la forme série ce serait
évidemment le centrisme globalement
c'est une forme centriste est d'ailleurs
à chaque fois qu'elle met en scène des
politiques virginie aussi le détail très
très bien pour d'abord elle et elle est
souvent faible sur la politique mais à
chaque fois qu'elle promeut disons d des
options politiques ça va être borgen
toute la série est vraiment organisé
dans la recherche de compromis permanent
à la danoise ou à l'allemand d'entre eux
le sandre la gauche et la droite où ça
va être bien sûr les fameux démocrates
américains qui sont en gros les
maquereaux d'islam à quoi ils ont
clairement donc il faut voir aussi que
ça va pas si loin que ça c'est les
déplacements subversif que son segment
proposera la série
[Musique]